you
about much for a Mad Dogs baiting how
much this guy's guy gave me
he sent me $350 look I'm gonna send you
$350 will you do a pack what can I get
for 350 s what he said I was like we'll
look I can't do a 5-foot painting for
that I could do a little painting and I
sent him a little thing I can do this
he's like great do it and you know and
you know send it to me so I'm actually
painting it right now I sent you a
picture I saw a picture the Joker knows
that that's a finished one this one's
not done yet I just started painting it
and it was a Joker
I said I can do it I'll paint a Joker
for you and put a little thing and he he
actually told me this is this is the
quote I want you to paint in it so I'm
gonna paint it and done and be done with
it and what was the quote Oh his quote
was he actually gave me a really long
quote I'm like look the painting is not
big enough to put all that [ __ ] in there
so you got a much text yeah some people
we ended up with some people just want
to watch the world burn and so I'm gonna
let that and it's the year perfect for
the Joker yeah it's a painting of the
Joker so how much it could be look if
somebody said hey look and I've got
another guy he said you know I'll give
you 500 bucks for something I haven't
done it yet yeah but I would for 500
bucks I'll tell you look this is what
I'll give you
yeah you know most of the paintings I
sell are like 750 I had a guy the other
day do one that was like 1,400 and I put
two it's gonna cost 200 bucks to send it
to ship it to him okay so usually
they're like 750 850 you know 650 I've
had some guys that have been like 500
bucks I've had a bunch of that we're
list 5 500 bucks I mean you know the
problem is it takes time yeah and you
know so it's the reason I like doing is
that I can do the painting and I can
answer comments and I can answer emails
and if Davey needs to talk to me for an
hour I can do that or if I need to set
up a Skype or talk to somebody some
producer that's like once this looked at
some of my stuff and it's saying hey
we're thinking about this you know can
you do this absolutely I can do that in
the middle of the day if you have a job
if I'm working at FedEx I can't tell my
boss hey tomorrow I got a
got at one o'clock I've talked to these
guys for an hour and a half they're
gonna be like bro no you're loading
boxes chains are doing tomorrow how do
you get through work on the construction
site when every Thursday at 11 o'clock
in the morning you have to log on to the
pre map under this to the supreme app as
you said the Priya app and cop the
latest drops how do you tell your ball
how did you offer to work at five
o'clock in the morning yeah but that's
lunchtime 11 o'clock lunchtime perfect
okay that's my question because every
year every Thursday at 11:00 me look
we're talking about it every Thursday at
11:00 you're always cop and Supreme
always got it so we're wondering like
what if you're what if you're like
mid-torso it's preset the day before
everything's ready to rock and roll so
you tell the ball time you tell the boss
the day before you are the bone nowadays
what do you mean to precess on your
phone you have a bot that automatically
cops it for you yeah there could be
things like that might be fraud I don't
know could be for HUD have another gummy
kid the crab looks tempting tempting
crab God what were you talking about
[Laughter]
what was that about that's that's this
guy that the guy that wants to produce
the other show he's saying that this is
good this is he doesn't like the
background here nobody likes the
background it's your mom it looks like
you're in your mom's basement and first
of all and all the grit look it's a
horrible color combination nobody looks
good anybody with olive skin looks
horrible with the with these colors I
look horrible the colors what colors if
you had a fine arts degree what would
you say we Matt what would you have
[ __ ] Edie Hardy in the background
just I know who had heard he is who's
that
affliction what did that come out during
the year 2006 mmm
laughs w19 see listen anything would be
better than this
yeah we were going for we were going for
like an old round 87 60s 70s I know if
you like psychiatrist and you achieved
it it was what you were going for was
wrong
really oh it was [ __ ] up from the
start you know what I liked before the
worst before you've been started big you
had the big yeah I didn't like that why
it looked more professional it look like
you were in a studio hmm
yeah it looks like some fake ass news
[ __ ] wack it looks like we're uh yeah it
looks like we're like news fake news Fox
News
[Laughter]
looks like we're [ __ ] CNN or Bay News
9 or some [ __ ] Matt we're not trying to
be futuristic here plus we have God
creating man and I feel like that's what
we're doing here yeah okay but what if
it was like two crab claws touching you
oh yeah that would be cool I wouldn't
Matt could you get use your degree and
make introduction bad laws could you use
your degree and turn that into to crab
claws touching other questions for the
[ __ ] of it this is Ricardo Villa here's
the thing though I love this guy he
really didn't go into it trying to rip
people off like Ponzi schemers who
actually ruined many personal lives
this guy just robbed banks with a pen
and a degree in fine arts is you scumbag
sure that's one you've read the best
kind of scumbag
the kind that ripped off insurance bang
[ __ ] them yeah there's no question
I like where his head's at it was a good
one man I'm drunk on crab juice you
really it's almost three hours not too
long I'll keep going should we wrap it
up let us know in the comments the crab
juice is talking and we'll sit here and
[ __ ] her and [ __ ] around for another
hour but I mean if you guys are getting
bored well sign off yeah you gotta you
gotta come up with so you come up with
some decent questions so we can actually
move forward do you want a 50 milligram
I don't know what that is I feel I feel
like I'll I feel like no it's called a
Terp it canna I feel like I will fail my
urine 300 mil definitely fill any test
yeah I can't klarissa's I'm sorry grab
me a beer will you
I can't dad don't uh yeah yeah
break it there's some more JD here you
want some JD no yes no they say they too
close to my mouth hole next three months
ago they call me Michael well Michael
Cox people want to know where the money
is
oh yeah I've heard that ones where is
the monney Matt when I was in his
hairline yeah this guy says max I work
at a bank and we don't do that kind of
stuff unless they have a debit card they
can either enter a pin on the ID is
legit and matches records and they can
answer as many questions as I want them
to ask that's why your good ones have
you ever been a victim of fraud oh yeah
I saw that when I saw that well have you
ever been a valuable prize honestly
great question
have-have I you know I mean stupid stuff
like one time I didn't know if this was
fraud it's like one time but like I
don't know it was like 40 or 80 dollars
or something came out of my ATM in an
ATM that I was nowhere near that was
like a cross just it wasn't mine was
just like I think was a banking error I
mean I've been burglarized a few times
I've had some houses broken into actual
fraud
the only thing closed to fraud for me I
think is that recently I tried to file
my taxes through like TurboTax and they
said someone else has already filed
taxes usually call they call that the
the drop whether you file for someone
taxes before the oh yeah
and so Isis I had to mail in my stuff
with a letter the IRS said hey I tried
but here's what they're saying is
someone else using my [ __ ] so I sent
that off but I just said I already got
your Trump check before you no no I got
my trunk jack oh you got a trump check
yeah I'm a [ __ ] Trump check me how
the so I went online and I applied I
said hey give me my trump check applause
if you haven't you'll put your info you
can go on the iris and why
and I actually actually sent something
to my probation officer and said hey hey
ma I gotta pay do I have to pay
restitution on this we're going we're
exempting all those checks
oh they're exempting restitution during
the pandemic not know they're not only
I'm just they're saying the check isn't
like if you owe 20% of everything you
say no we're not gonna hit your [ __ ]
check for that oh nice so I was like
what'd you do with it I paid my I paid
my bills I have to it nothing fancy
didn't treat yourself treat myself bro
on I paid my friend good Red Lobster
nothing it paid for gas from Red Lobster
so I could do this podcast I got the
crispy crab I'm just saying with the
Trump check did you yes I might have
went out and treated yourself something
nice
I just let's not reimburse Mike from all
the crap that I've had to pay out it's
just $1,200 gotta pay listen I know guys
that people are getting like 2 and 3
like they got like four kids a wife that
doesn't work it they're getting light
$33,000 and stuff oh yeah unemployment
people are getting like three grand a
month so I'm like that four grand a
month
yeah three grand a month I thought it
was three thousand bucks a month take
six hundred a week that's twenty a
little over 2,400 yeah sure and close
still alive you [ __ ] money oh yeah
goddamn captures hazmat ever climax
during sex to Bon Jovi's run away that's
some hard-hitting questions no I have
not I have not but it's it's it's
something I'm gonna look into cool look
forward to have you ever owned a gun if
so what kind i I had a concealed weapons
permit and I had a gun when I had a
concealed weapons permit but that was a
like maybe 20 years I was I think I was
like 24 25 I had a gun I think I had a I
had a know I had a 357 mm-hmm and I had
a a 9-millimeter both Smith where Smith
and Wesson Wesson good both were Smith
and Wesson my girlfriend had a lady
Smith the girl I was dating at the time
and then I and honestly I think that I
think the concealed weapons permit was
good for like two years or four years or
some and then it just expired because
when you take that class you kind of
realize I really don't need to be
carrying a gun because if I I'm going
somewhere where I think I should carry a
gun yeah I shouldn't be going there
right then don't go there
somebody just donated $120 really ah
come to Vegas and blow money with me
Danny better split this with UPS I just
had to one of the last guys
experts met cash you should have a cash
app they could just say no right dad no
you need a bad mouth and only fans it's
an app where you just poke eggplant with
your debit card to people who just send
you money or the eggplants for only
three I create only fans Matt somebody
wants to know if they PayPal you money
can you send them a signed book and send
it to Australia by the way big fan I
would have to I mean I could do that I
could do much what I can't well I mean
you know I think I'm wondering soon did
you yeah typically they buy the book and
they mail it in my toolbox I get it I
sign it I mail it back to them so I'm
not sure how that changes that other
than I'm doing all the work for you
right so yes Matt to do all the hard
work yeah you want the books I buy the
book
send it to him he'll send it I probably
endless tampon we should buy like five
or six books but how often does that
happen I mean tell him look my my email
is you know contact Matt Kopp Earth's
contact Matthew Cox at gmail.com
that's a [ __ ] mouth full contact well
I'm not Matt nice was taken Matthew its
contact table Matthew dot cos elle.com
right and it's Matthew with two T's yeah
got that so for a minute Matthew with
one T yeah really yeah great question
Matthew with one two yeah definitely
[Music]
they're out there
[Laughter]